don't be long you mean a shame on you
mangy
bismillah money more here
assalamu alaikum - laughs cut
greetings of peace the best of greetings
the greetings by all the messengers of
god the greetings of jenna and we're
greeting you with those greetings here
today forgive me for being a little bit
late but alhamdulillah that I'm here
with you today
in hamdulillah not me - who want a Stein
who want to stock Pharaoh when I
would've allowed him in Shu Rudy and Fuu
see now women say yeah I'm a Lina Mayor
Naheed LA who follow model Allah I'm a
you little fella hadiyyah-lah well I
shadow an inner heel Allah WA the hoola
Cheri Keller wear eyeshadow na
muhammadan abduhu wa rasuluh indeed our
praise is for the creator of the heavens
and earth Allah we praise Him we seek
his help we beg for his forgiveness
that's amazing the blessing of being
able to praise the all praiseworthy I
mean people they praise human beings
when they hit a jump shot when he scores
the touchdown
maybe writes a nice speech the guy wins
a match they put him on his shoulders
give him the praise but when we're
praising Allah this is the crater that
happens an herb do you get it do we get
it do we understand this is the one who
created the birds and the bees the seven
seas the galaxies the one who says kun
fiyaquun' be and it is
isn't he worthy of all praise I get
excited
praising Allah and Allah the creator of
the heavens and earth out of his love
and mercy he sent messengers and
prophets to guide humanity and that came
to us through the Dawa
that's that invitation the call to share
because if we care then we're gonna
share and that's what all the messengers
of God did they call the people out of
darkness into light they came to revive
the hearts to wake up the hearts of the
people because people are indulging in
one thing or another and usually they're
indulging in the wrong things so the
simple call through this Dawa
was that call of pure monotheism some of
the messengers we know Noah called his
people to Islam submission to the crater
not the creation Moses Abraham Jesus
Solomon and Mohammed being the last and
final messenger sent to mankind now we
see that through this tradition when we
read the verbatim Word of God the Quran
we see the constant theme over and over
is this call they were sharing because
they took up this mission given by the
Creator and now as they call humanity
they didn't come to win a popularity
contest they called these people away
from idol worship away from creation
worship and as they went on they
overtook hardships and obstacles that
came in their path but they overcame and
today we need to continue the legacy
because now if we don't share do we
really care and the last and final
message my problem Hamid peace be upon
him he said one doesn't truly believe
until he loves for Humanity he loves for
the people what he loves for himself so
do we love the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him who said in another authentic
hadith he said that one doesn't become a
true believer until I am more beloved to
him than his mother his children and all
of mankind so how do we love problem
Hamid peace and blessings be upon him by
following his sunnah not just getting
emotional when someone maybe draws a
cartoon doing things opposite to the
deen going in hysteria but by following
his sunnah and edifying educating the
people creating awareness that's through
the Dawa that's through the Dawa
and Allah has told us in many places in
the Quran verbatim word of God the
speech of Allah who do alas a valeera
bookable hikmah to invite all to the way
of your lord with wisdom everyone woman
Asano : me manda ah ill allahi wa amma
la sala ham walk allah in a Neiman el
Muslim meaning and who is better in
speech there's no one better in speech
except the one who invites to the
worship of the One God and does good
deeds himself and says I am one of those
who have submitted I'm a Muslim I'm like
Jesus was I'm like Moses was I'm like
Abraham was they weren't neither Jew or
Christian but they were ones who
submitted themselves entirely to the one
God they were Muslims and they did the
dower so over and over we see the theme
in the Quran is this Dawa inviting
people to good and the ultimate goodness
is this relationship with the Creator
Allah says in the Quran will acid in El
in Santa fé Huson in ladina amanu wa
amma la sala haughty what the world saw
bill Hucky what the world saw be sober
indeed all mankind is in loss bankrupt
but don't fall into despair because
allah gives the good news here except
those who believe believe in what father
son Holy Ghost believe it money is your
God believe is the son that's your God
the creations are God no they believe in
pure monotheism the religion the way of
all the prophets and messengers and they
do good deeds they back it up because
talk is cheap you need to back up that
belief with good righteous actions and
those who invite encourage one another
to the truth and patience and again
the ultimate truth it's that call to
worship none other but the creator of
the heavens and the earth and to do good
deeds we see so many examples from the
Sidra of the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him of his grieving
and his deep conviction and love for the
people and Allah in the Quran subhana wa
ta'ala in surah kahf he consoles him
saying will you kill yourself out of
worry and grief that many of them are
not accepting the call so we see that
constantly day in and day out he was
calling people to that which will pull
people out of depression anxiety despair
we live in a society where
self-indulgence this I phone iPad I
touch I this I that this extreme self
individualism where people are just
unhappy families are broke society is
broke and people's hearts are yearning
for something alcohol drugs sex and rock
and roll this is not feeling it it's not
doing it
people want Prozac antidepressants and
we have the antidote we have it yes
Islam gives lifes to the heart and now
imagine people who are thirsty and you
have the water and now you pass these
people up and you don't share and
they're thirsty and then someone else
comes and fills them up with alcohol
intoxication their minds with hate
rhetoric comparing that to the
Islamophobes and these racist bigots who
now just are fueling people with hate
and false fear because they're not
getting the correct information and
they've done a poll I don't know how it
is
here but in 2014
2010 there was a poll that showed that
27% of Americans I don't know about
Canadians had a unfavorable image of
Islam now that went down 5% from 32%
back this is 2014 27% in 2010 it went it
was at 32% and it keeps declining why
are we taking up the call what happens
when you're running with the baton with
the light and it's passed to you and you
don't continue on as we see in history
how would we have been given this
message if the dawa didn't continue
going at a time when the Muslims those
worshippers of the crater the Muslims
they were a a merely 300 from the Battle
of other and then the treaty of
hudaibiya 1400 and then the conquest of
Mecca 10,000 strong they came it came in
with no but bloodshed spreading the
peace spreading the food and in the
farewell sermon hundred twenty thirty
forty thousand strong from how did it
reach that much from 1400 to 10,000 now
the peace was established the treaty of
hudaibiya
and now the Muslims can go out and they
could interact they took up the call
what if they just set back being
entertained not taking the message
seriously would we have gotten it here
today and then it continued to grow
100,000 plus strong and then one of the
Prophet peace be upon him say those that
are here go and convey to those that are
not here and now we have it so as people
are filling their bellies in their
pockets with money the hearts are empty
the hearts are empty and we have an
obligation now
another iron the Quran where the crater
that heavens an earth
he gives a warning in surah al-baqarah
chapter 2 verse 159 as to those who
conceal the guidance and the clear
proves after Allah has made it clear in
the car add those bring upon and this is
a little scary but we have to speak the
truth sometimes because we see again
allah as all the messengers they brought
the good news the glad tidings of Jenna
and the warning for those who follow
their lusts desires
sorry about that and do not heed the
call but it's a warning for us too that
the curse upon upon those who conceal
this guidance after Allah has made it
clear the Prophet peace be upon him
reiterates this saying that you will
enjoy what is right and forbid what is
wrong or otherwise Allah will send a
calamity upon you and you will make
supplication to allah and he won't
answer it Allah loves you
along wants the best for you and this is
something that now if you have a friend
who has a migraine and all along you had
two advil in your pocket and you didn't
share we gave the example of the water
or now you have the cure for cancer
and you don't get out there and give the
people two antidote it's not our job to
convert anybody but it's to share and if
you care you share as the Prophet peace
be upon him had said again until you
love for the people what you love for
yourself how can your Deen can be
complete how can we sit back and enjoy
all the basketball and the football
playing the Xbox getting this getting
that but now we've abandoned this number
one mission that's a part of our purpose
so those were just a few of the ayahs
and the examples from the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
and we say that we love him but when we
love him again we follow his way
that's the way to gender and he had said
in authentic hadith in Timoney he says
those who love me love my Sunna and
those who love my Sunnah will be with me
in Jenna do we want to be with the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
Jenna
so his Sunnah was the Dawa his Sunnah
was conveying this message something to
think about because we don't want to
just come here and then we hear all the
speakers all the scholars and all of the
encouragement and then we walk out and
we forget everyone to their capability
and that's the beautiful thing
Allah is not going to ask us about the
results right now is the planting ground
of goodness good seeds gonna have good
fruits and those best seeds are the
seeds of the Deen Allah will make it
grow in the heart but it's on us now to
plant those seeds and then in Jenna in
the next life that's when we see them
grow so when you see the example of
Ibrahim alayhi Salaam when he was thrown
into the fire why was he thrown into the
fire why because he was trying to win a
popularity contest
no because he went against the odds he
called people away from what they were
doing of ship of associating partners
with the Creator and he called him to
the pier monotheism they didn't like it
it was bad for business so they threw
him into the fire now the example here
is the Frog
we know that the Frog looked there's so
many animal rights in Islam but I'm just
speaking on this tiny example about the
Frog you know a little frog is forbidden
to kill the Frog in its log what can he
do when you have a fire that's five six
stories high and the little frog is
taking some water and spitting it in the
fire
subhanAllah he's putting in some effort
to his capability and a lot hunted him
for that subhanAllah but what about us
what about the effort that we're making
to go ahead and talk with our colleagues
talk with our co-workers what effort are
we making and all of this
we know that when WOD even's ever when
he was sent and this is one of the
sahaba that the Prophet peace be upon
him he loved him he said mo I had I
loved you can you imagine if the
messenger peace be upon him he loves you
and he does and by following his Sunnah
as he said the one who loves me
follows my Sunnah and the one who
follows who loves me will be with me in
Jenna so how do you love him by
following the Sunnah so he's telling
Mourad he sent him to the people of
Yemen he said let the first thing be
that you call to is la ilaha illa-llah
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the creator of the heavens and
earth and muhammed is the last and final
mission and this was automatically
include not exclude all the preceding
messengers Jesus Moses Abraham and all
those that came before him it were the
same message of Islam and then at the
end right before he was leaving he said
I heard the Prophet give me this advice
sallallahu alayhi wasalam that perfect
the good manners with the people in the
dealings with the people so along with
the information we are ambassadors to
disdain by representing it in the way
that it's supposed to be resent
represented with the good alack
so now we have this base so we have the
formula for success because this can
also be a hindrance when we don't do the
simple things thank you you're welcome
you're being foul you are expressing
yourself in a vulgar way this can also
be a deterrent from the Dawa so this is
another thing I wanted to touch upon now
I want to go into before I conclude is
the ABCs of Dawa so we talked up a
little bit about the
Gatien from the Quran and the Sunnah and
now how simple it is and I give you an
example from Abu Donna this is another
companion of the Prophet peace be upon
him because some people some people are
like oh my god
how can I do this it's so difficult I
need a big beard I need to be a big
Sheikh go study for four or five years
no it's very simple but you have to know
what you're speaking about from the
little that you know so Abu daughter he
came he heard the call he came to see
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
and he spent maybe ten minutes with him
maybe a little more maybe a little bit
less salat wasn't revealed at this time
zakat wasn't revealed but he had been
educated on the simplicity of this call
of the pure monotheism of only
worshiping the one who created you Allah
and ascribing no partners with him and
being good to the family being good to
the people he left fifteen some odd
years later he came back now remember
what how much time did they spend most
of you here no more than he knew and he
came back with his whole tribe and they
had all as the Prophet peace be upon him
had told him to go off he wanted to
follow him in at that time but he sent
him off and said come back when we were
the message is established he came back
when it was in medina he said do you
remember me he said yes and he brought
his whole tribe and they all had
accepted la ilaha illallah muhammadur
rasulullah all of them takbir
we gotta wake you guys up to beer
subhanallah but how about us ABI said
ABCs it's easy as ABCD everybody knows
ABCD so a let me leave you something
with something tangible practical a we
have to attract so we talked also about
the good o'clock the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him said I have not been
said except to perfect good manners good
character so we need to attract people
in different ways and one of those
beautiful ways is through that lack
personal hook having the good manners
and etiquette that Islam promotes and
then other unique ways you're on the
airplane you pick up or you're at work
and you open the the Quran and people
get fascinated I'm just giving you one
example you can come up with with other
ways and now people get attracted they
see the Quran the calligraphy what's
that mo Muhammad all you didn't change
it yet okay Muhammad what's what's that
he said oh this is the Quran and then
that conversation strikes up and there's
been known situations where from here
someone had made a request they wanted
the Quran and subhanAllah to end up
reading it their heart opens Allah
guides them they accept Islam be build
the bridges we need to get involved in
different community activities seeing
some brothers now get together cleaning
the streets and people see there's a
rapport now established they see that
these Muslims are not talking about
hurting anybody terrorizing blowing
things up themselves all of this stuff
is false rhetoric has nothing to do with
Islam see focus on some commonalities
and a beautiful one is this love and
reverence that we have because many
people think that these people are the
Antichrist but no when we say no we love
Jesus and we can go to the Hellfire if
we don't believe that he was one of the
mightiest messengers sent by God but we
don't worship Him we worship the one
that he worshiped and his Blessed Mother
we love her too you see the
commonalities people they don't know
this
this is another example that's a B and C
and then D deliver the message deliver
the message
again oh my god how can I do that
I just explained how simple it is and
let's go again we said the ABC attract
build the bridges commonalities and
deliver again leaving you with something
tangible that inshallah I will stick oh
my god
oh the oneness we want to concentrate
you don't start to jump into things that
now have their place and you talk about
halal meat you talk about the Jin you
talk about this debt now and and and
everything else you want to talk about
the most important thing is the oneness
the pure monotheism could whoo Allahu
Ahad say he is God Allah the one and
only the absolute the eternal he begets
not nor is He begotten and there is
nothing comparable to God talk about the
attributes of the Creator that he's
without beginning without end he's truly
self-sufficient he doesn't need food or
drink water
he doesn't rest on the seventh day he
doesn't get weary or tired he's not
ignorant of anything this is powerful
stuff so stick to this oh my my M the
messengers for God so loved the world
that he sent prophets and messengers to
guide humanity yes and then G the
guidance because of his love he sent it
and we have it today in the book that's
tamper free tamper proof unchanged
uncorruptible it's a living miracle the
Quran at the example of the last and
final messenger prophet muhammad peace
investing to be upon him these are some
simple steps da was fun that was easy
not only does it help the people that
helps you to develop a relationship with
Allah a better relationship it urges you
because you don't want to be out there
ignorant so the more you stir I've
interviewed so many people subhanAllah
that come from other walks and ways of
life
and what we see a common thing is the
more they started to study the religion
that they were upon from their
upbringing the more it turned them away
but the more we see that you study Islam
sincerely because it's based on evidence
and proof because it's from Allah the
Creator the more your heart continues to
open and it grows you develop this
certainty and you grow any man and you
want to give more you want to share more
you just can't help it
and that's where the Dawa comes in and
at the end you talk about this and then
you deliver the message and at the end
you know that it's not upon you to guide
the people we talked about those seeds
being planted and now it's on the
Creator Allah when you put the tomato
seed in the ground who makes it grow the
vegetables the fruit who makes it grow
you don't make a girl just put it a seed
in the ground Allah makes a girl Allah
opens the hearts but you did your job
just like that frog he did his little
part that's what you'll be questioned
about the effort that you put in that we
put in so let this not be something that
goes in one ear and out the other
let us make a change let us make a
different difference starting today that
we go out we have so many different
programs that we've done at the Deen
show calm that you can go ahead and
share in your emails the Deen show calm
you can visit us there subscribe to us
support us on our Facebook on our
Twitter right now if you have these
phones Android go ahead right now like
us on the Facebook we have a Facebook
page and share this get out there
communicate this message and as we said
as I opened up earlier and I'll close
with that well asset in l-insana la fere
who said allah ladina a man or army
loose ollie hardy whatever so be lucky
what the WHA so be sober Salaam alaikum
too long
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
greenies a piece how many hosts of the d
show the first and one of the only
Islamic TV talk shows in America going
on five hundred episodes strong
alhamdulillah and there are a lot of
people spreading misinformation about
it's not a lot of Islamophobia is
growing and they're able to in a matter
of several years raise almost a hundred
million dollars for what for a good
purpose no for a noble cause no for
distorting the truth for calling people
away from peace
you know Islam calls people to peace to
have peace with their Creator peace with
themselves and peace with humanity so
creating this fear and anxiety in people
having people look at Islam as the other
have having people look at Islam as the
boogeyman that's coming to get you but
when people turn into the Deen show they
see this is absolutely not what we've
been seeing we have more of a chance of
dying from secondhand smoke we have more
of a chance getting bitten by a dog and
dying or getting get this getting killed
by our own furniture that's right
so people we need to get the facts out
and I'm gonna not we've been successful
at changing the perception that a lot of
people have and many people have
accepted this way of life and the work
continues at hamdulillah so do your part
can contribute you know there are multi
billionaires out there with money just
overflowing from the bank accounts if
not multi billionaires you also have
multi millionaires with one check with
one click of a button they can finish
this campaign and always help when the
people who are doing the Dawa they can
have a clear and focused mindset they
they don't have to worry about these
secondary issues they can just focus on
what they're doing and you have people
out there who are sponsoring so you know
what I got your back whatever it takes
to keep this going is done finish these
are the people that I need to step
forward and if it's not contributing
towards the Deen show find an
organization that is out there promoting
this piece promoting an understanding
edifying educating the people about this
Deen a fast is going way of life in the
world that's right
and support that cause so you have a
great opportunity here to contribute and
support the Deen show or any other
organization that you feel comfortable
with but do something do your part get
out there and share because if we really
care we're gonna go ahead and share and
this is my message to you contribute if
you haven't already helped us to
continue the work and inshallah God
willing we can move forward all together
and get the wonderful rewards that the
Creator has promised for those who
contribute towards the Dawa we'll see
you next time
inshallah Eid Mubarak